reportage sur ce nouveau
phénomène avec Romain Schué.
- Salut Romain. Il y a une auto
qui s'est parquée cette nuit.
J'ai marché hier, il y avait
rien. Je l'ai suivie un peu.
Ça s'en va là-bas, vers
les États. Moi, ma terre est
à 700 mètres des États-Unis;
15 minutes puis tu es rendu, là.
- Martin Gamache habite
au chemin Fisher, une route
parallèle à la frontière,
à Hemmingford. Il observe sur
son terrain de plus en plus de
migrants traverser la frontière
pour entrer discrètement
aux États-Unis.
MARTIN GAMACHE,
résident d'Hemmingford, Qc
- Il y a un véhicule Uber qui a
débarqué dans mon entrée, puis
là, il a débarqué un dénommé
Pedro. Il s'est en venu ici
à pied. Moi, j'étais sur
ma terrasse, puis il y a
deux Mexicains qui sont sortis
du bois. Là, Pedro, avec
son petit sac a dos, est allé
les rejoindre à pied.
- Martin a même accueilli
chez lui une famille visiblement
perdue et sans ressources.
- Ils avaient les pieds
complètement mouillés, gelés,
il faisait -25 dehors.
Ils étaient complètement
congelés.
- La route, même si elle
est courte, n'est pas facile.
Il faut traverser ces bois
et ces champs et éviter
les caméras, bien cachées
dans ces arbres.
Et tout le monde n'y arrive pas.
Le nombre d'interceptions par
les agents américains a explosé
en quelques mois, passant
de 70 en mai dernier
à presque 400 en novembre.
Et la tendance se poursuit.
Juste durant la première semaine
de janvier, une centaine de
personnes de 11 pays différents
ont été arrêtées dans
ce secteur, côté américain.
Cette hausse fulgurante, Hélène
la voit depuis sa fenêtre.
HÉLÈNE GRAVEL,
résidente du chemin Roxham
- Un matin, je me faisais
un café et il y avait une dame
qui passait, à pied, au teint
foncé, avec un enfant.
- Dans ce coin, au bord de
la route, il y a des cache-cou,
des peluches accrochées
aux arbres et même des valises,
visiblement pour montrer
le chemin à prendre.
- C'est pas prudent d'entrer
dans la forêt ici. Ce sont des
forêts qui ont vécu le verglas :
il y a plein d'arbres par terre,
partout; c'est vraiment
dangereux. L'autre côté existe :
on va peut-être en parler un peu
plus parce qu'il y a un homme
qui est mort.
- Le corps de Fritznel Richard
a été retrouvé ici le 4 janvier,
dans ce boisé, à quelques
centaines de mètres à peine
du chemin Roxham. Il serait mort
de froid après s'être perdu
durant la tempête qu'a connue
le Québec à la fin décembre.
Fritznel faisait partie
des 40 000 personnes arrivées
au Canada par Roxham depuis
près d'un an.
FRANTZ ANDRÉ, Comité d'action
des personnes sans statut
- C'est loin d'être un cas
isolé. Je connais au moins
10 personnes ou bien des couples
et autres qui sont retournés
depuis... depuis novembre 2021.
- Frantz André aide
les demandeurs d'asile
depuis plusieurs années. Le rêve
canadien serait malheureusement
devenu parfois un mirage.
- Je crois que le Canada
est un bon pays d'accueil.
Par contre, depuis maintenant
la COVID, les choses se sont
compliquées. Ça a mené les gens
justement à être désespérés
puis à prendre des décisions
qu'ils n'auraient peut-être pas
dû prendre.
- Frantz est en contact
avec la femme de Fritznel.
Elle aussi, elle a quitté
le Canada avec l'aide
d'un passeur en passant par ces
bois, mais pendant l'automne.
Ça coûte combien de faire appel
à un passeur pour retourner
aux États-Unis?
- Ça peut aller jusqu'à 1500 $
et peut-être plus.
- C'est qu'on force
d'une certaine façon les gens
à franchir la frontière
de cette façon-là.
- Selon cet avocat, ces migrants
seraient prêts à payer
et prendre beaucoup de risques
pour entrer aux États-Unis.
Me STÉPHANE HANDFIELD,
avocat en droit de l'immigration
- En fait, la clientèle,
elle est différente.
Les gens qui passent par
le chemin Roxham, ce sont
des gens qui veulent être
pris en charge par les autorités
canadiennes; alors que ceux
qui veulent traverser du côté
américain, c'est tout à fait
l'inverse. Eux ne veulent pas
être pris par les autorités
américaines et veulent
se fondre dans la nature.
Et malheureusement, ils sont
prêts à emprunter des voies
qui ne sont pas toujours
sécuritaires.
- Malgré les dangers, beaucoup
y pensent et beaucoup le font.
Il suffit de rester un peu
au bord de la frontière, loin
des policiers du chemin Roxham,
pour le constater.
- Ça fait que c'est sûr que
venir ici, c'est facile.
Tu débarques, il n'y a pas
personne qui te voit.
Il y en a de plus en plus,
des petites Caravan blanches.
Tiens, en voilà un!
Ça, ça a pas rapport ici, ça.
Des cubes comme ça de location,
ça, on en voit souvent de ça.
- Je ne comprends pas
qu'on arrête pas les passeurs,
qu'on fasse rien pour s'occuper
de ces gens-là. Parce qu'ils se
mettent des sous dans les poches
avec la vie des autres puis
le malheur des autres. Moi,
je trouve ça d'une tristesse
infini